Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two. David P.. I got a
very funny voicemail about how was I even able to
enjoy my vacation, given that I didn't have with
me all of the different products and services
from our sponsors. Take a listen to this. I
get it's a joke, but I like it anyway.
Speaker 2: David, sir, how were you
able to enjoy your vacation without
access to your two week tube system?
He was mattress or your shower head. I know.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I had to deal with
actually the mattress at the place I
stayed was was really good. But yeah,
I had to deal with the total inability to cool
my mattress with the chilly sleep product that
we have as an advertiser. I didn't even have
blue choo. That's a joke, by the way, guys,
but that is one of our advertisers. I didn't have
my blue blocks glass. I didn't have anything on
the trip and somehow I still had a great time.
OK, very good. We have a great bonus show for
you today. First and foremost, I'm going
to address head on on today's bonus show.
Why has the bonus show been a disaster from
the technical standpoint on Monday, Tuesday
and Wednesday? The explanation is a sort of simple
one, and I'm going to even ask for help with it.
Also, Delta Airlines, which never refers to
the Delta variant as the Delta variant. They
always call it like the one six two one seven or
whatever. The whatever the number is, they don't
want to call it the Delta variant because they're
Delta Airlines, which is sort of funny. Delta
Airlines is going to be charging unvaccinated
employees an additional two hundred dollars per
month for health insurance. Why? Well, because
they've made an actuarial calculation and
they've determined our cost for unvaccinated
individuals over time is going to be higher.
Are people going to quit Delta Airlines?
We'll talk about it on the bonus show.
And then lastly, we have an update. It is not
going to be a recommended third dose at the
eight month mark. It's going to be a recommended
third dose at the six month mark. And of course,
this is leading people to ask, am I going to
need a booster every six months? And also raising
questions about why don't we have a booster that
is tailored to Delta rather than the same old
shot from twenty twenty. And we were going we're
going to address all of those different questions
on today's bonus show. Get Instant Access. I
would love to have you on the bonus show. Really
sign up. But join Pakman Dotcom. It takes only
seconds. You can use the coupon code, my hip,
my hip, a refrain from many anti-tax Republicans,
my hip hipper use the coupon code, my hip to sign
up at. Join Pakman Dotcom. You will get a huge
discount. And oh, people. I got a bunch of emails
saying, David, what interviews are upcoming? We
have a bunch of really good interviews upcoming.
Thom Hartmann is going to be joining me soon. I
also am excited many people recommending Vincent
Racaniello. I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly.
One of the hosts of the This Week in Virology
podcast. He is a virology professor at Columbia
University, a brilliant guy from the standpoint
of virus. He will be joining me. And we've got
a bunch of other great guests upcoming. So I'll
talk about that more early next week. But for
today, grab that membership. I will see you
on today's bonus show or sadly otherwise, we'll
have to wait until tomorrow to be together again.